hi this is an unscheduled video to this
crash course and that's because this
video is a correction video I made a
mistake in the last video where we
talked about ozone and radiation in the
atmosphere now radiation is something
that I don't study as far my PhD it's
not something that I have specialist
knowledge of and it showed because I got
something quite fundamental wrong I got
an email from a postdoc at Oxford who if
you're watching by the way thank you
very much pointing this out and thank
you for watching where I made a key
mistake in saying that nitrogen and
oxygen in the atmosphere absorb long
wavelength radiations so they absorb the
thermal wavelengths that's not true
carbon dioxide and methane and similar
compounds actually do the absorbing of
thermal radiation and that's something
which we're going to talk about in
greater depth in a future video I
wrongly assumed that nitrogen and oxygen
did the same thing basically and I
didn't do enough research so I'm sorry
to you that I made a mistake but I
thought it was important enough to merit
a corrections video trust me it's
embarrassing to get something wrong when
it's this fundamental this basic but
it's more important to be correct in
education than it is to have an intact
ego so correction for the last video
nitrogen and oxygen don't absorb thermal
wavelengths in the atmosphere instead
that's carbon dioxide and anything
seeing as I'm here I may as well also
say thank you very much to everyone
who's engaged with the series so far
it's been wonderful to read your
comments and I just like to say that if
you are enjoying this series then please
do comment and leave likes and favor and
all that kind of stuff because that's
how I know that this kind of content is
being appreciated if this gets good
enough response and to be honest it's
getting a very good response so far but
if it gets more comments and more likes
than I will start planning more series
like this in the future they are a lot
of work but if they're well received I
don't mind that so if you want to see
more of this stuff then do support it by
commenting equally if you would like to
support this series and my other videos
financially then you can do so I just
set up a Conners page which is a great
educational website that allows you to
track your progress through educational
series like this one we also have the
opportunity to donate to the Creator
which is me so if you would like more of
this kind of content and if you'd like
it better then you can absolutely donate
there equally if you don't have the
money or don't want to then
you find because I realized that a lot
of people watching this are students and
you don't have the money to spare so
yeah but if you would like to support me
then that's how you can do it for people
who've been asking thank you very much
for watching and normal service
hopefully without any mistakes will be
resumed in a couple of days where we're
talking about the stratospheric polar
vortex okay so here's my work but it's
important because it's a book I like
books and it's got the working that's my
laptop which has got the scripts with
crash course videos in that's my
Japanese piece Lily always important to
keep that around because it keeps the
air oxygenated that water he'll hydrate